now errol musk has more reasons than
many to feel fatherly pride to be honest
269 billion of them to be precise his
son is the billionaire spacex and tesla
mastermind elon musk
although a engineer and a self-made
millionaire himself he has six other
children so perhaps he agrees with
elon's view that population collapse is
the greatest threat facing modernized
civilization uh he joins me now uh errol
musk good evening welcome to uh piers
morgan under censor without beers morgan
my name is jeremy carl how are you
i'm well thank you jeremy nice to talk
to you uh there you are in south africa
can i i suppose i would start by saying
um thank you
i mean you you you created this business
genius and yet it would be fair to say
errol that all of your kids are high
achievers which means it's all down to
you is that right well that's what you
say
well they are all high achievers
so it would be wrong for me to say that
anything else
why do you think they are
um i think
it's uh ins
built into
the sort of a work ethic that we
inherited from uh
our parents and you know grandparents
and so on
i mean you were
you know you run a major engineering
business you were a millionaire by the
age of 30. one wonders whether
your kids would have had the same
success actually it's an interesting
subject over here at the moment with
everything that's going on about
opportunity and what you're born into do
you think that elon and all the other
kids if they hadn't been born into that
wealth would have been less successful
well of course of course
they they were used to
things that it
made it not necessary for them later on
to uh have those things because they had
many of those
nicest things when they were when they
were children is um i mean let's take
elon the world's richest man did you did
you did you put the wind in his sails
did you did you set him on his way or
was it all him because i mean you know
he's the richest man in the world and
you're his dad that's quite impressive
well you know uh
of course you know i always encourage
him and uh
we've uh
never turned away from hard work
and um
we have a sort of um
grasp over the world where we feel
that
we are able to do things and so we want
to do things and so we try to take on
things that other people say can't be
done
that's that's that's about it you know i
i get that take it on spacex and tesla's
quite different to your average take on
a different job uh there was a bit of
controversy this week which is why you
wanted to come on uncensored because you
said that although you're proud of him
you don't really like him very much but
you said that you were misquoted i i i
mean what are you jealous of me man i
mean i think i've been jealous of myself
i'll tell you one thing if my son was
the richest man in the world i'd phone
him every day
no
no i never said anything like that
so i i have been proud of him
from the day he was born
and uh a person doesn't suddenly become
proud of your child no
that's ridiculous
and um
yeah and and then as far as saying i
don't like him i mean that's crazy you
know well i know i love him you know i
know that you felt that you were
misquoted and we wanted to put that
right so a few more questions no
provider of the world's most richest man
uh do you think that uh his business
ventures are good for the climate
oh well i think in terms of the overall
thing they're not making a great deal of
difference on the rocket side i mean
obviously i suppose i mean if you're
talking about rocket trails
but um most of the stuff they burn is
hydrogen
so
on the car side obviously there's a
little bit of uh
carbon saving using electric cars
of course there's coal generated power
stations but
maybe in due course we won't have that
either um somebody i read somewhere this
week described your son as sort of iron
man so my question is quite simple is he
a superhero or a flawed evil genius in
his father's opinion
no no
no he's a superhero superhero
he's a very very nice person
i never thought that i would help anyone
errol that's lovely i never thought i'd
be asking this on television um a
colombian firm has asked you to donate
what they describe as your super sperm
because you seem to produce children
left right and center more than me i
mean my dad before he passed said go
back to work because you're going to end
up with more kids than boris johnson but
yours are all billionaires and all over
what is it about you ma'am what have you
got that the rest of us haven't errol
well well i'm it's 10 it's not 10 pounds
per ite per
per little individual you know
okay
just just no i i'm not doing that oh
right okay i did it worried me that it
was colombian but that's just my opinion
um i noticed earlier you talked to you
talked about being a strict parent on a
serious note is that
something that you think helped all your
children go and and and go for their
goals in life
oh yes
absolutely
i mean they were traveling with me when
they were tiny i mean
all over the world and i couldn't uh
keep an eye on all three of them
so i had to rely on them you know and
point out to them you know in china or
whether
especially my blonde daughter in china
they want to you know that is not safe
and
and and so i had to rely on them and i
made sure they understood that i relied
on them
and i did not tell them
what to do i never signed anybody's
homework in my whole life
in fact i was quite surprised uh one
time when uh
the kids were boys in high school they
grew up with me
they were raised by me and they grew up
in high school
i mean uh they grew up with me and
they came to me with uh one day i was at
a function and
a parent mentioned that
it's about signing homework
and i said signing homework
and then later i spoke to my son kimball
and i said
what's this thing about signing homework
he said oh dad don't worry i mastered
your signature
years ago yeah listen many many kids
would have done that now here's a quick
question i haven't got much time um does
elon turn to you for advice i mean i'm
thinking i'm thinking twitter 44 billion
or whatever does he say dad what should
i do because i just want you to know i
joined twitter today for the first time
you can follow me jk official and i just
wanted to know what i was expecting if
your son's gonna buy it my friend
well um yes
i do give them advice obviously from day
one
and
obviously elon has a lot of other people
giving him advice
but i hope he takes my advice
um so is the twitter deal going to go
through errol
i was asked i two years ago i
applied to be on twitter
and i was told that i was already on
twitter
and that
i had
458
posts
so i said no i'm not on twitter and i
have to get hold of the
family company to to uh
ask them to tell twitter that that's on
me
so there's obviously something not right
there
very quickly um you advised your son to
get security you said he's becoming more
and more political is that advice he's
taken from you
well i hope so i definitely hope so
and um it's a very important thing very
very important it certainly is and a lot
of crazies out there what a what an
extraordinary man you are ten children
to three women you make me look like
i've done absolutely nothing you're the
father the richest man in the world and
you look fantastic if i look like that
at 79 i'll be well happy uh thank you so
much for joining us if he does buy
twitter tell him to get me that blue
tick because honestly i've only got 12.
listen i've got 12 supporters in one day
jesus had 12 and look what happened to
him uh listen errol martial thank you
follow me mate thank you very much
indeed uh errol musk live from south
africa great to have him on uncensored
you